for high school students in england this
is their welcome back to school in 2022.
you've got all right to the top
not here all the way to the top
okay five five right there it's gonna
make your eyes water yeah
a swab up the nose for every pupil to
check their covid free and ready for
class and in the classrooms masks are
back and recommended for the first time
since may
rules in england now align with scotland
wales and northern ireland where pupils
have worn masks for months the uk's main
teaching unions have called for more
from the government resources for
testing staff absences and classroom air
ventilators but winston community
academy's principal is making the best
of it the additional guidance that we
had around um mask coming in was
supportive of that because we really
want the children to be here um nothing
replaces being in a classroom with other
children and so having that and the
lateral flow tests the vaccinations that
are happening all seem to us to be
measures to kind of keep schools open
and that's what we really want to be
happening workers are back after the
holidays too though london bridge
station's rush hour was noticeably quiet
many people either following advice to
work from home or isolating with covert
there were
only
six or seven people on the floor were
the critical resources and mostly 95
percent of people are working from home
so how is it at work i mean are there
many people off
but they're
less than half of the office so yeah
over the last seven days more than a
million britons have tested positive for
covid 19. the government has tasked
ministers with planning for a worst case
scenario of one in four people being off
work
if anything close to that figure is
reached then keeping vital services
going is going to be an uphill struggle
several hospital trusts have already
declared critical incidents it's what
health bosses do when they're worried
they can't provide priority services
on tuesday evening boris johnson said
the country could ride out the omicron
wave without shutting down the economy
but the weeks ahead are going to be
challenging
both here in the uk
and across the world there is no
escaping the fact that some services
will be disrupted by staff absences
and if we all play our part in
containing the spread of this virus the
disruptions we face
can be far less severe than a national
lockdown
reasons to be careful reasons to be
optimistic perhaps but the storm
certainly isn't over yet rory challenge
al jazeera london